[Musique]
sensibiliser les familles les plus
fragiles et les plus éloignés du livre
et leur montrer l'importance de la
lecture dès le plus jeune âge ce sont
les objectifs de l'opération premières
pages qui s'est déroulé ce mercredi 29
juin dans les jardins de la villa du
département ce bout du livre sa facture
dès le plus jeune âge mais vous
comprenez bien que on s'adresse aux tout
petits à travers l'opération premières
pages et à travers les patrons à travers
la famille les parents et leur bébé né
en 2020 et 2021 reçu un exemplaire du
livre terre l'année n'a ici il y à une
balade au coeur de la réunion là le
concours la place comme ça dans une
bible à cause par l'homme depuis quelque
temps mais l'antenne fait un travail
avec la petite enfance de plus en plus
jeunes les bébés tout ça l'était une
continuité donc mal était évident
d'aller
hier un public de petits tout petit
j'espère que
apprécié découvrir et d'aimer les
couleurs qui vous
ce que c'est
un album écrit en français et en créole
qui a fait l'objet d'un concours depuis
2015 le département en partenariat avec
l'adac océan indien et la caf met en
avant la création locale et la
production éditoriale réunionnaise donc
qu au moment trois belles cascades y
coule tout le temps
aux cormorans trois belles cascades qui
tu es à la nana ici il y a vous voyez
que vous avez écrit en français en
créole et en français le créole c'est
important on doit aimer notre langue
maternelle pas caennais nous on doit
maîtriser le français c'est un combat
que mène depuis des années presque vingt
ans donc c'est une suite logique me
direz pas une consécration parce qu'on
ne va pas parler jusqu'à là mais en tout
cas le fait que le public n'a accès à ça
de manière aussi aussi nombreux parce
que là on a quand même catherine plus
capé d'exemple at a été imprimé donc il
veut dire que nous soyons
beaucoup de marmailles que va manipuler
sa vive et puis la langue les deux
langues ou face à face est content pour
2022 ce sont plus de 26000 fanni qui
recevront un exemplaire de ce livre
[Musique]